father and son walking to pay tribute to
those killed in the war both of them
were injured in the fight against russia
says he's getting ready to go back to
the front once he has recovered
this is not a celebration this is memory
celebration will be after the victory
when everyone returns home alive and
falling we have many losses now
it's independence day in ukraine but
there are no celebrations this year
because of the war
it may have been 31 years of
independence from soviet rule but the
fight for freedom people say is more
alive than ever
in this past six months thousands of
people have been killed and injured
millions have been displaced this is a
memorial side
to remember those who have been killed
in this conflict
there's also this book that you can see
here where people can come and write
their own personal story
of loss
they have been coming here steadily all
day
remembering those they have lost
it's it's a big concern because ashil de
pre says the war has caused extensive
damage especially in southern and
eastern ukraine where the fighting is
ongoing
we've seen all around ukraine as a
result of this conflict a tremendous
amount of suffering of physical
suffering of also mental suffering a
population that is traumatized we've
seen you know critical infrastructure
damaged or destroyed including water
infrastructure also
health facilities also educational
facilities
some really basic goods are very hard to
come by including food including water
president celenski reaffirmed his call
to recover the territories occupied by
russia
he walked through the center of kiva
accompanied by british prime minister
boris johnson
hundreds of destroyed russian tanks were
put on display on the street an open act
of defiance to russia
zelensky had said moscow was planning a
series of cruel attacks on independence
day
the enemy thought we would greet them
with flowers and champagne but received
wreaths and molotov cocktails instead
they waited for an ovation but got
explosions
the occupier believed you could parade
through the center of our capital
you can witness this parade today in
krishna street
the proof that enemy equipment can only
appear in the center of kiev looking
like this burnt and destroyed
on wednesday air raid sirens sounded all
day across the country
a reminder of the imminent threat but
people in kiev remain on the streets
many say they've been afraid for too
long
this year the marking of independence
has a different meaning
people say they are still fighting for
it
and the only option they have against
russian aggression right now is to win
the war
teresa